I have absolutely brutal video for you
Tennessee Republican Governor Bill Lee
is going hard anti-drag and anti-trans
and was confronted with pictures of
himself dressed in drag years ago this
is just unbelievable let's go right to
the video first and then I will tell you
all of the details but this is oof this
this is something take a look at this
that's on your desk drag Bill heads back
to the Center for a quick Amendment
before it's your desk comfortable
signing those types of legislation yeah
I expect to sign up Josh
what a ridiculous ridiculous question
that is conflating something like that
to sexualized
sex realized attainment in front of
children which is a very serious subject
Andy Scott
Andy
I think that the concern is uh what's
right there in that cloud in that
building
um children that are potentially exposed
to sexualized entertainment to obscenity
and we need obscenity come on dude to
make sure that they're not I think
that's something that should happen in
Tennessee that will because of this bill
would you be okay
because this is you this is you at a
high school Governor this right here is
you at a high school yeah is it only
illegal when gay people do it
have you talked to your sister about the
bill governor
all right so the everything about this
is just wacky first and foremost you
know the the idea that there is
um some
oh predatory nature to the drag queen
story hours or we've already talked
about it we've we've looked at it
extensively there's a sort of mishmash
happening which really shouldn't between
the drag queen stuff and the trans
bathroom stuff and these really are two
separate issues we interviewed a drag
performer a couple of weeks ago who
explained like you might be trans and
also be a drag performer but there
really are two separate things let's
look at a couple articles excuse me a
couple articles here The Daily Beast uh
drag Banning Tennessee governor shrugs
off old drag pick as a light-hearted
tradition with Billy poised to sign a
bill outlawing drag performances imagine
that an apparent photo from his high
school yearbook has surfaced
the other thing that was mentioned in
all of this by the way is obscenity that
they're concerned with Tennessee already
has obscenity laws so if the concern is
obscenity or sexualization that already
is handled by Tennessee law and so
claiming you need this new law doesn't
actually make any sense a photo emerged
writes The Daily Beast on Reddit over
the weekend from the Franklin High
yearbook in 77 where Lee attended
purportedly showing Lee dressed as a
woman along with the caption hard lock
Hard Luck Woman but that's different
Lee's office told The Daily Beast saying
lighthearted School Traditions shouldn't
be conflated with what the state is
Banning the bill specifically protects
children from obscene sexualized
entertainment and any attempt to
conflate the serious issue with
light-hearted school Traditions is
dishonest honest and disrespectful to
Tennessee families when asked during the
press conference if you remembered it he
didn't deny the photo was of him but
said it's it's a ridiculous question NBC
news reporting Tennessee governor
appears to have dressed in drag an art
form he wants to restrict
there are sort of like three different
things here
as is so often the case with these
right-wing clowns there's the personal
hypocrisy now on the issue of drag you
wouldn't think like how does this keep
happening Kerry Lake I give very
dangerous drag queens Carey Lake uh
organized if I recall correctly a drag
performance and at minimum attended it
uh Billy we're Banning drag because it's
sexualized and obscene and this and that
oh he'd rest in Drag and actually the
law already bans obscenity okay so the
one part is the hypocrisy the second
part is as I started to mention the
actual thing they say is the problem
with drag isn't really the problem but
if it were meaning the obscenity or
whatever A lot of these states already
have so-called anti-obscenity laws on
the book so you wouldn't actually need
these bills and then number three is
what the reporter asked which is is
there a single specific example you can
site
of what it is that this bill would stop
and you know we went through this with
the Trans bathroom stuff which is okay
so it's going to stop uh men who say I'm
a woman in order to go into the women's
room and spy on young girls and take
pictures and
we already have laws against that and
there are no examples of that happening
from states that are more Progressive
when it comes to the trans bathroom
stuff so it's again a solution in search
of a problem to Virtue signal if you
want to learn more about virtue
signaling we have a clip on the YouTube
channel that I did last week so nonsense
all around
great to see Bill Lee confronted these
people are clowns these people are
virtue signaling they're playing into
these culture wars and they're doing it
in a horrifyingly authoritarian way
one of our sponsors is zipx nicotine
toothpicks don't you think it's time you
stopped putting smoke and vape oils in
your lungs zippix toothpicks are a
convenient way to curb the nicotine
Cravings zipx toothpicks are super
discreet you can use them anytime
anywhere smoking and vaping aren't
allowed including flights sporting
events in restaurants they're available
in six different flavors with options of
two and three milligrams of nicotine if
you're not a nicotine user zipix also
offers caffeine and b12 infused
toothpicks zipx has already helped tens
of thousands of customers ditch the
cigarettes ditch the Vapes they might be
able to help you too if you're a smoker
or a vapor give zipx toothpicks a try
your lungs will thank you go to
zipxtoothpix.com today save 10 percent
with the code pacman10 at checkout out
just remember you must be 21 or older to
order the link is down below